To understand the goals of IPSec,
let's take a look at a critical
weakness of our IPv4.
In IPv4, there's no authentication
of the source IP address.
That is, if Alice receives a packet
with Bob's social IP address,
Alice cannot be sure that
the packet is really from Bob.
As a result, IP spoofing or
forging the source IP address
is a commonly used
technique in cyber attacks.
For example,
bots in the botnet can send a DNS query
to DNS servers asking the full
TXT record of a domain.
By spoofing, the source IP
address of a victim website.
As a result,
the response from the DNS servers
which can amount to a very large volume
of data is sent to the victim website.
And this would result in a
denial-of-service of the victim website.
IPSec provides security
measures at the IP layer.
This include authentication
of source IP addresses,
confidentiality and
integrity protection of packet data.
And authenticity of packet data, in
particular preventing replay of packets.
Of course,
a network application or protocol
can implement its own specific security
mechanisms to achieve these goals.
By having IPSec, that is implementing
security at the IP layer,
we can ensure secure networking
not only for applications to have
a security mechanisms, but also for
many applications that are ignorant
about security because all application
run on top of the IP layer.